upholding values for a stronger Europe
dw's christian toughie talks to vice
president of the european commission
viviana letting ha leading savales
rating you have said you won't go to the
winter olympics in sochi why not yeah
well gancio of course i won't be going
to Sochi that's because there's such a
high level of discrimination in Russia
against minorities this discrimination
takes both legal and social forms it
will be sending the wrong signal to go
there and support those policies in dust
MIT einem hindi and sawdust rates
questions are you counting on other EU
officials to join your boycott at the
games I certainly hope so the Austin
wouldn't it be more effective if Europe
sports associations announced that they
would boycott the games to protest the
lack of civil rights in Russia yeah it's
been well I'm a politician not an
athlete I don't want to interfere with
the independence of sporting
associations for meetings isn't
imitating you've been active in European
politics for nearly a quarter of a
century you've been a commissioner for
almost 15 years now your portfolio as
justice Commissioner includes basic
civil rights in the EU what's the
biggest area for improvement mr. ostilow
there are so many healer but once your
biggest worry a zagg and neat i buy
house it's not a question of worries but
of challenges the problem is that ever
since the Treaty of Lisbon we have had a
legally binding charter of fundamental
rights that's a very good basic legal
structure for Europe but we have been
weak on implementation on putting it
into practice so every time things start
to go wrong in Europe I raise my voice
and it gets noticed he be- dimmer or
divert done the mat dispute the german
news magazine Der Spiegel has described
you as a nuisance and the Frankfurter
Allgemeine a newspaper calls you the
inconvenient commissioner
sobbing how do you live with such labels
yeah offer ich bin by my glove
inconvenient for anyone who doesn't
observe the basic rights of Europeans
sometimes that means raising my voice
and making my point by banging my fist
on the table we have basic rights Europe
is not just a big common market it's a
gathering of cultures of people who
should feel free and comfortable here on
this continent it's a serious challenge
to protect these values and that's what
I have to face as commissioner Vega
actually have our Father home or dare
challenge me some even go Zach you said
you don't have the tools to make these
rules take effect and to really
implement them what specific authority
would you like to have which isn't as
force of insurances ish via Conan yeah I
know press charges against a government
for failing to respect these basic
rights but I can draw the world's
attention to these regimes and that can
achieve quite a lot I think that
national politicians have started to
point out cases where other countries
don't observe european rights and that
started since i became commissioner and
it's still continuing in politique
that's allowed sue shiniest medium
finger ultimate fought and i'll finish
but after him giving government's now
know that there is a voice in europe
that will speak up loud and clear when
something goes wrong in oh ho / aunties
act loud tight leash when advice she
flushed solution did without or we need
to rebuild trust between the EU and the
United States we've been hearing this
from every corner ever since the
revelations of the US National Security
Agency's massive surveillance of Europe
citizens how can we rebuild this trust
is it even possible on video here it's
austin fat horns it takes time to earn
trust and you can lose it very quickly
yeah Edward Snowden's allegations about
us spying confirmed what many people
already knew perhaps we didn't know the
extent of it but we knew that what was
happening here which was in
contravention of
european law was actually legal under
American law sheet but I've gone from
americarna Shroomish legal is thus we
demand that Europeans be treated in
accordance with their rights and
according to the law British per hundred
verdun aha and that they have the
opportunity to defend themselves against
these attacks in American courts Ashton
in our meal that's not possible at the
moment nikia file but now I see the
possibility coming into view nation
Mughal a severe than gets the team
urkesh card Alfonso con been Zenon was
when you're involved in negotiations
with the US do they understand that
protecting personal data is so important
in Europe positions or halt scooting
over place long at site happens it after
a long time they didn't understand and I
always had to refer back to our history
many of our people come from
dictatorships with a right-wing or
left-wing they're sensitive about their
personal data deletion got an
unblemished lava is far but I think it
was the story of Angela Merkel's mobile
phone that showed the American public
that something is wrong with the
intelligence agencies methods and how
they apply to citizens as well as
politicians in Europe undertaken in
Oaxaca um Guillen one zinta banished
aligned the American Americans aren't
the only villains in this story British
intelligence services have been
monitoring communications in friendly
countries on a massive scale German and
French intelligence agencies have used
information given to them by the
Americans German politicians have been
acting outraged is that hypocritical via
hibernia in Oaxaca in Europe we have
laws that cover has security agencies
and secret intelligence agencies operate
they don't get to operate outside a
legal framework that much must be
clearly understood and that's why it's
actually a good thing that these
scandals have leaked out and become
public that means that individual
countries governments are making sure
that their secret services are following
national and European data privacy laws
this is thus forcing
what's in Europe do in addition to
individual government's efforts to
protect personal information would see
via harbans I we've had European data
privacy laws on the books since 1995 and
for the past two years I've been trying
to reform those rules the European
Parliament is on my side they've agreed
across party lines to data protection
laws that would cover all of Europe
these laws could be put into practice
because they would give Data Protection
Agency's the power to impose sanctions
publish chitin also stood but some
individual governments have not signed
up for this I would like them to rethink
their position convention above iced but
would a pan-european agreement on data
protection protectors here in Europe
from surveillance by US spy agencies for
in Upper accion and we can trade
institutions in each gave it in and I'll
give you an example say you have a big
American company that has a lot of data
and has a subsidiary in Berlin in anger
seeded is then if the American security
agency's request access to its data in
order to vacuum it all up to skim it or
love then there's no way to refuse even
if it's against the law in Germany it's
legal in America and that's what counts
and the fines that are handed down in
Germany for abuse of these laws are tiny
if it ever gets that far that's why
European law has to change and why it
has to apply to all of Europe for guns
or bargains on there have to be stiff
fines up to two percent of these
companies worldwide revenues that would
force them to think about whether they
will abuse people's rights in Europe or
not Macpherson Dawson order nisht mama
and big as to Britain will the British
let themselves be dictated to by a
European Commissioner when it comes to
their own intelligence agencies Robert
was flying over PA from comas our ins
argan yarmulke in Britain is thus its
comfort
the British don't exactly know where
they stand they have one foot in America
and the other in Europe but it's time
that Britain decided whether it wants to
be European or not I'll page sanville or
damaged thus current ones that could be
interpreted as a suggestion that Britain
should leave the EU line is know what
I'm suggesting is that they decide where
their allegiances lie if they're with
Europe then Britain has to follow
European laws and not just cherry-pick
the ones they like for example in Europe
we have four basic legal categories
covering freedom of movement that
applies to goods services and capital
and also to people guten fun servicer
and fun capital about our phone bill
Britain doesn't want people to be able
to move freely but you can't just throw
that one out and keep the rest either
you take advantage of the common market
which means you have these four
categories of free movement or you don't
participate and then you don't need to
respect citizen's right to free movement
garnish dancer Elton Sam's Eden in the
hunt starting on January the first
Bulgarians and Romanians will also have
the right to free movement in Europe how
can you force Britain and maybe also
Germany to respect the law flights a
week I'd sagen Simone I'm ear stand ya
know out absolutely nothing will change
on january first all european citizens
have the right to go wherever they want
in europe for three months laughter when
these three months are up they have to
show that they're not a burden on the
social system of their host country the
social systems of the affected countries
are under the authority of their
national governments I've told these
governments very clearly that they have
to do their homework and make sure
there's no abuse of social welfare laws
in their territory and that if they need
my help they'll get it zod see allagas
that's a gift Renzi gabon even they got
the message chopard I see dicen message
fresh done and hub it's in decent buy
lady needs two countries but also
elsewhere you hear people say that if
this freedom of movement has a negative
impact
rich countries social systems that will
play into the hands of right-wing
populist ists Papa listen indian doses
for zine argument yeah own kids and a
severe and i take that question very
seriously this argument and sr puppy so
in recent weeks i did an analysis of the
information we have the fact is most
people who come from an EU country to
Germany or Britain or Holland come there
to work not dodge ram they are a net
plus to their host country's economy
dusty common also our Bible doesn't let
thoughts Allah as there are very few
people in Germany it's just four point
two percent who are a drain on the
economy Tasha llegan or van de league if
they're in the country illegally then
it's up to German agencies and the
German government to deal with that and
to stop it dare doctrine beholdin on da
dodje navigable yeah the elevating vice
president of the european commission
thank you for your answers to dw's
questions yeah it's my pleasure